[Music]
lorient
went to [Music] went to high school
[Music]
Sainte-Marie
dynamic sanitation systems
[Music]
he had to
serve large and he
[Music]
existed but
they didn't  not offer
since the press release that we are Wednesday the
little forearm course like that he
lights up and robin in
bischofshofen great challenges they also told me at
dawn - vichy
that would have
allowed belletti
in
the municipal world
the  about maths at
risk changed in appearance
but I
quickly
understood
everything was done very quickly
cordoned off the surroundings
of a therapy request is
[Music]
located only one thing that he
would have
changed everything tried to
banging the
[Music]
mjc
baby
[Music]
gym
doesn't tickle me too exploded the league
like there are the spurs
[ __ ] good things said lorenzo
match and it's claude this technique said
[Music]
said confident
adam shine analyst  e se
[Music]
pronounce
like vers check list with a humble
Libyan design but committed on two
women from the communities
no but
[Music]
the level is this sir
[Applause]
[Music]
I know  all the same to cause
studios the sweet kind and she lied
all normal
[Music]
and particularly
wizards for the industry in front of the
success of thoune be live
international wide below and
laboratories
a
piece the cdi all makes sense
the big challenge a piece to federate
[Music]
and as the batteries
are warm and this contact
judicial liquidation she participates at
all levels to god give us
society on
our young billy payne in
national
all
this
n
102 of the finger such visit was
d  elsewhere
of illusions cheaper the tourist by
also participating or
hiking her ten chains saturn
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause  ]
here is 10 in
[Music]
beijing
[Applause]
[Music]
ok
I'm going to renault the
linkedin title slips all three of the
forces
pro gbagbo
and his five children  accelerated from amélie
in is was conquered
always melodic and hypocritical that these
include
all my fans for these
the workforce a
design of
minds
and governed & cie sees a
direct exposure and where it evolved from a
suspect there are books  this is
the one who is
[Music]
as an excuse the cocistes was
and where the
[Music]
civilians under money but he neither
and the
communities the two
economies
everything
reads the
technical music system to him  was m yes we will have that
there is a
field of panels from security gis
fraud and as
it was
[Music]
still a
comedy not and that if you choose where
they are a
trial but if he has
committed others
bolivia programs have come to life at
[Music]
jo  uer
when can easily
[Music]